Vice for a 73-year-old male, just received blood work back showing DHS is only 5 range
should be 229 to 284, can supplementing with DHEA-B beneficiary for our necessary for
the elderly. Okay, so DHEA is a hormone that's created in the adrenal glands. So the adrenal
glands create DHEA. DHEA is also a intermediate metabolite that then produces testosterone. So
it is part of your stress hormone system. It's part of your adrenal hormone system. And giving
a person DHEA, because you can buy DHEA supplementation out there. But I'm going to tell you I am
against it. So if you supplement with DHEA, because it's a hormone works on a negative feedback
loop. So if you supplement with DHEA, you will literally turn off production of DHEA. In this case,
you could say, well, this person doesn't have any anyhow. What's going on? Well, you have to ask
the question, why again? So you have to go, why does this person not have any DHEA? Is the person on
testosterone-lowered medication? So a person that has prostate cancer that's on the energy
deprivation therapy, that can actually affect DHEA. And maybe that's the cause of it. No,
let's say pretend that's not the case. I don't know what the case is here. So I don't know who this
person is, but let's pretend. No, they're not on a loop run. They've never taken that. What else could
lower DHEA? So first of all, you'd want to test for a complete adrenal profile. You want to test for
cortisol too. So if the person has DHEA in the pits like this and their cortisol is flatlined,
then you know they have complete what's called complete adrenal burnout in layman's term. So they
have complete adrenal fatigue. So you need to build up the adrenal glands again, step number one.
But you also want to find out why. So there could be the reason why, could be this person has burned the
candle at two ends for a long period of time. Maybe they're in a very, very stressful relationship. Maybe
they're in a horrible, horrible work environment. Who else? But you got to figure out the reason why.
It can be because they have antibodies to the adrenal gland. It can be because they have two
Terry issues. There's a whole bunch of can be. So we got to figure out the reason why. If you just
use DHEA in this, you have to be careful because again, not knowing the complete history is a detriment
because if we, if the person does have prostate cancer and you give DHEA, you will actually be simulating
testosterone production, which may not be what you want in this case. Again, if they don't have prostate
cancer, I think you should look at testosterone levels also. So doing a complete Dutch test, the UTCH
is really an order to really answer this question. I'm not a fan of using DHEA as a supplement. Unless
the person is, you know, we cleared all the other things and there's, there's things in their life
that they cannot change. For instance, I've had people where they have, they're in an abusive
relationship that is not changeable right now. And their, their body is just completely burned out
and their cortisol levels are flatline in the pit and their DHEA is, is, is burned out like this.
Then you give DHEA for a short period of time just to get them over the hump.
But if we really need to look at the complete picture, this, for some of like this, we really should do
a case review and do some further investigation. It wouldn't, it wouldn't be.
I think it's really wrong when practitioners, when you see, that's why it's wrong to get your advice
from Instagram and Facebook and things because if you don't look at the big picture, you,
you're just, you're basically, again, throwing darts at the wall and it can be very dangerous.
I just actually had a conversation with a person this morning that got was on DHEA
from another practitioner and I had to explain to them, this is not that person, but
I had explained to them that same thing that you, you're just shut down your DHEA and we actually
did a Dutch test on that person and their DHEA was, was at the bottom of normal. And it's like,
well, how was that when you're taking it? It's because you're shutting down your adrenals by taking it.
So I'm not a fan of taking exogenous hormones unless you absolutely need it. Let's say your thyroid
is just shut down and you have Hashimoto's and your energy is down, well, you're going to have to take
an exogenous thyroid, but then you have to understand that you're going to be on that for life and
and there can be a lot worse things of life than beyond exogenous thyroid. But why just shut
out of your DHEA adrenals by taking this without figuring out why? So